hello everyone this is amir from
audioscience review i have uh one of
those fundamental videos for you
it was prompted by a comment from
manufacturers saying that we don't need
the accurate uh frequency response
measurements and
also that you can't measure distortion
of a speaker in a room
i could just quickly answer that both of
those are wrong but i thought instead
make this an educational
video on uh fundamentals of how we
perform modern measurements and not just
speakers but also headphones they use
they're both transducers
and uh while men some people understand
this at high levels versus what what the
signal is i don't think they understand
the intricacies of of uh how the signal
processing works and how the fundamental
math and science work uh i'll get a
little bit into the math and science but
uh bear with me the high level picture
should be understandable by most of you
and if you learn this boy you'll know
more than 99 of people out there
including experts in acoustics and
engineering because again math is
involved and whenever math is involved
people prefer to not dive in on this and
frankly this information is not widely
known except for people that deal with
instrumentation
okay so the idea is how do we measure
frequency response and distortion
this is the technique indeed used in the
measurements that i'll show you
so
i've got a powerpoint in here so let's
work through it
the key about measuring
headphones and especially speakers is
that
they have depend as the frequency goes
along from 20 here to 20 kilohertz the
behavior of the system can change
drastically for example you could have a
port at the beginning of a speaker then
a woofer takes over but meanwhile
there's mixing of the two sound sources
coming from different angles
and then the woofer goes for a while
then it starts to roll off and a twitter
and a two-way speaker takes over but the
port may have resonances than that mix
up in that region and at any rate the
drivers may have distortions and they
may do all things as frequencies go uh
go up
and
you know the purpose of the measurement
isn't just to say well you know the
speaker goes from 80 hertz to 20 killers
that doesn't tell you much we want to
know how it varies in between those and
importantly what clues can we get as to
the competence of the design whether
there are things that are overlooked i
just measured the active at a very cheap
speaker called the swan heavy x3 and
this is his frequency response i just
post this
and
it characterizes you know everything
that i just talked about look at this
frequency response starts at 20 hertz
ignore this part because it can't
reproduce this area but as it goes up
there's a little dip in here
and the question is you know why is it
dip there then we go in here then it
gets this really messy area in this mid
region and that's caused with from
multiple resonances uh from the cabinet
and the port that's coming out and the
review i uh show that and then
you know we see that there's a there's a
resonance a two resonances in here we
can see their peaks over here and then
another monster residence that goes up
and comes back down and then there's a
gentle roll-off so maybe this part of
the response is smooth and flat but the
rest of it is you know got quite a lot
going on in here and if you just showed
me this one graph alone i could tell and
i just did tell you a lot about the
design of the speaker what is wrong with
it you know
things that you know need the
investigation and thinking about
importantly when i perform listening
tests i
pick content that hits on these issues
and listen for them
no reason to listen to this region
because it's nice and flat in here but
you know here the mid frequency messed
up there's a peak in here and so forth
so
you know frequency respond isn't just
the casual thing you throw out with a
low resolution graph that doesn't go
this deep but it's something that tells
you a lot about the design and that's
the purpose of you know my presentation
and my measurements it's not just throw
one or two fluff measurements out there
as an augmenting some subjective review
just to have a checklist measurement
section
um but to really dig in and find a
difference between you know speaker that
has important cabinet problems
like this one in this region and one
that is absolutely clean and pristine
there and this kind of coloration
normally is not seen in low resolution
measurements
and uh the resolution of these if what i
call acoustic events is just generic
term for uh you know things that can
happen needs to be quite high look at
these peaks in here and the chewed up
response they don't spend more than tens
of hertz in here and
so if you have a resolution that's very
low all this gets filtered out then you
walk around with some dixie thinking you
don't have important cabinet resonance
issue but you do and the ear hear some
of these things now as we go higher the
equivalent rectangular bandwidth of the
hearing system gets wider and wider and
things become less audible but still we
need to know these things before we can
do this psychoacoustic analysis i just
did very quickly
if you don't give me the data then i
can't do that analysis for you
needless to say anybody doing serious
speaker design is performing similar
measurements and is paying attention to
these things and and cleaning up these
things
um and by the way this is very important
for developing eq if you want to correct
these
issues you want to understand their
nature of them because that lets you
then program the width of the filters
you put in and so forth
um
research also has been performed as to
how can we take a graph like this that
is anechoic meaning that it is
independent of room but predict your
preference for a speaker when you put it
in a room and that research
relies on having 120 of them is 20
points of of resolution per octave
in here and that matters a lot in lower
frequencies where you could lose a lot
of resolution in other techniques
excuse me
so um uh my
measurements about 120th 124th of an
octave is what i show but other people
show you one third of an octave which is
you know useless for this type of
analysis okay
so this is why it's important so it's
not about absolute accuracy i'm not
giving you a better number vertically in
here of 85 versus 86 or 85.222 we don't
care about that level accuracy we care
about mostly
accuracy in this dimension the frequency
domain where we want to know things are
happening so that we can distinguish one
problem from another and if you're
tweaking or fixing a speaker you can go
in there and have the tools to fix them
okay
now
the classic way for years and years and
years was to perform what is called a
step sign uh measurement frequency
response we would play a 20 hertz tone
be well it'd be very low frequency feed
it to us to any product and then take
the output and filter out the 20 on
whatever i mean take the 20 and that
becomes the amplitude of the response
and then change the tone to another one
another one another one another one
now
that works fine
if you have very few points because each
measurement takes time you have to wait
for it to stabilize and uh to capture
that accurately and it can take you know
as much of a quarter of a second if you
want to really wait and average out
noise but if you go quick you know i'm
just measuring 100 to 200 points can be
five or ten minutes affair and if you
think about a frequency response of 20
to 20 000 you basically need 20 000
points if you want to have one hertz
accuracy and uh
20 000 points would just take insane
amount of time for just one measurement
and in case of you know what we do with
the give you a spherical view of the
speaker we'll take an infinity to
measure that all around the speaker so
it is not a practical thing for
measuring acoustic products but it is
perfectly fine for electronics where
nothing happens at that minor graduation
so this is a name um
unity atom uh streamer that i tested a
couple days ago a few days ago and this
is his frequency response and i think i
don't know if i use 60 points or 100
points in this and you can see some
gentle things happening here
but otherwise
you know it's not anything happening
here because we don't have all these
complex interactions of drivers and what
have you this is electronic device not a
electro-mechanical device so
um but know that if we could do 20 000
points this is the most accurate thing
why is it the most accurate because
maximum amount of energy is focused at
one frequency at a time and the
measurement that frequency is perfectly
accurate of course if you jump to
another point then connecting a line
between them that line is no longer
accurate
okay so this method can be used with
speakers but it almost never is uh
because you know 100 points if i uh go
back to this 100 points in here would
tell us nothing you know it'll be you
know
one or two points in here and you
couldn't even plot this graph let alone
see all this detail
okay
so
we want to come up with a clever way to
do this where we measure at all
frequencies so
with one test wouldn't it be nice if we
just place a magic tone in their magic
signal in there
that it just gave us all the frequencies
at once
well at the theoretical level we can and
that's called an impulse function an
impulse function is a signal that is 100
quiet then it goes 100 on and in zero
time it goes to 100 off
and uh if you did that if you perform
this is a time domain right i'm telling
you what happens over time if you take a
fourier transform transform of this you
see that it's a horizontal line which
means that we it has a fixed amplitude
at all these frequencies and therefore
if we fed the second system this
vertical line what comes out then is
naturally frequency response because
we've excited every frequency
now i said this theoretical because in
real life no signal goes from zero to
infinity back to
zero
in zero time we just can't do it and uh
you know people resorted to all kinds of
things in the olden days they even would
take a cannon and fire it off to try to
generate a very powerful signal that
went up very loudly and then came back
down
so and even the shotguns were another
substitute so
um
this method was just is you know rarely
ever used for uh measurement
so people want to find
other signals that have these kinds of
characteristics
and by far the most common one for a few
decades was with this uh uh oh it's just
multiple let's just say maximum length
sequence
and
uh about two spelling errors their
sequence is also spelled wrong
um mls um
it uh
i'm not gonna talk a lot about it
because it's actually fallen out of
favor but if you go on for example
stereo
stereophile
and look at their measurements of
speakers from that era
you will see that there is a package
that uses mls in their first measurement
and
the idea is that
if you take random noise like white
noise
it also has
a full rich spectrum of of the uh
of frequencies and that therefore that
could also be used to run through a
you know speaker and then listen to it
and if you ever have an equalization
system where when it runs the uh test
and goes sh
and you hear that you know going through
the speakers that's what they're using
they're using this mls signal and
it to make this uh tenable to be able to
compare what goes into what comes out is
that you don't use actually random
sequence you use a very well known
sequence that's easy to generate and
then easy to recognize
at the output of the device and be able
to tolerate delays and latency errors
and so forth
using this you can get uh basically uh
you know full frequency response out of
this but the problem is that it it's
actually a noisier signal in that it
doesn't energize every frequency as much
as a step sign did you can depending on
how it's done you lose between 8 to 12
db and that's a lot of
dynamic range to lose if you're going to
measure for example speaker in a normal
room with some kind of noise floor you
don't want to lose 8 to 10 db or 12 db
of your dynamic range and
and that causes also accuracy errors
basically you're getting the you know
measurement errors um the science the
math behind this is it's complicated to
understand but just at high level no
this was technique that was common for a
while uh but every modern system today
it will recommend using this system or
this is their default system in addition
to step sign if that's available
so let me talk about what is the modern
system
some people have heard the name chirp
measurements but
excuse me the technical term form is a
log scale swap sign
so
i'll talk about the details but this
came by
innocent looking paper by professor
angelo farina uh from university
department in italy and uh
it's an innocent paper it got published
it's not very long it's uh i don't know
four or five page paper and he used very
simple tools an audio workstation cool
edit pro i don't know how many of you
remember that that free editing tool and
and managed to come up with a
way of testing and generating the signal
that had that not only fixed some of the
deficiencies with mls but also
the distortions the harmonic distortion
falls out and gets generated at the same
time
so not only do you see the frequency
response you immediately also have all
the harmonics also available to you with
the same measurement normally when i do
a measurement of frequency response it
doesn't give me distortion i have to
measure that separately with step sign
but not with this very very very clever
paper was published in year 2000 by the
way he was one of first people to get
things online i remember taking his full
acoustic course on this really old
website is from his full semester class
where he starts the class and
immediately tells all the students that
the class will be in english and every
student must be able to ask the
questions in english and
otherwise they better leave the class
and
it's good in a way that he was he knows
so much of the literature out there in
this fields in english so it's forcing
the students to be proficient in english
on that and there is you know low
resolution videos but it's still fun to
to go through them one at a time and get
to the end very very well done on basics
of acoustics anyway we sidetracked let's
go
and say uh
what that is when you have a lock swap
sign um you give it a a duration uh of
how long that that signal this signal
goes
and it sounds like a bird chirping and
that's where the name comes and the
reason goes very quickly is that every
doubling of time it doubles the
frequency so it quickly becomes
exponential and just finishes very
quickly so the beginning of it is slow
and then goes
and to the f um you get to decide the
length of this chirp and i bet you the
people don't understand what i've been
explaining and what i'm going to explain
i had no idea what that is but basically
the longer that that
that chirp signal is uh the higher the
resolution so uh i have said it to be
less than one hertz of resolution so
when you see my speaker measurements
they have less than one hertz and you
really want to get down to one hertz
accuracy in in base frequencies um
because that's that especially if you're
measuring your room and you want to
design filters for that
and
the drawback is that the longer you make
it the longer it takes to test and with
the
coupled neutral scanner we make a
thousand measurements so it does
accumulate even though the chirp can go
you know it's still two you know i don't
know two or three seconds still pretty
short but it can add up over time if you
don't make it one measurement then it's
not a big deal
now i'm gonna try hard not to drag you
into the mouth of this thing but
uh essentially if we take a four-year
well i'm step back the problem we have
is that when we run a signal through the
system that's sort of known what comes
out gets delayed by timing errors and
what have you and you can't just compare
the two because they're out of sync with
each other uh using a
statistical uh signal processing
technique called cross correlation you
can basically
filter that out and that works by
basically taking a fourier transform of
the input and the output and just
dividing them with each other and
what this gives you is that is the
frequency response of the device under
test so it's you know even if you don't
understand what a 40 transform is their
libraries
that go and do that generate the thing
for you basically transforming from time
to when the frequency domain and boom
this comes out and then uh if you need
the impulse function you then provide
use an inverse fft on that and that
becomes important in a second when i
talk about distortion
um and that's what we're at so
uh
if you
get the impulse function you see this
kind of this uh
data that's presented in the graph form
but you get a data this is the impulse
response of of our speaker that's being
measured so this is what our frequency
response gets driven from but if you go
on negative time
you use at a specific point that's known
given the length of the
chirp signal where you get the second
harmonic impulse response then you get
the third harmonic fourth fifth and
sixth and seventh you can see it gets
all the way to eighth before it blends
into the noise floor in here and uh
if you take one of these things and
apply fourier transform to it you get a
frequency response which i'll show you
in a second now one issue one thing we
can do clever on this noise is that we
can apply uh averaging and averaging
since this uh noises tends to be random
noise being ambient noise that the
microphone is picking up by averaging
we're able to actually reduce the rms
value
of the noise floor allowing these
impulses to peak above that noise floor
a lot easier
okay
so what does that look like
we get a continuous graph just like we
give a frequency response but now of all
the harmonics so
this is a dark blue that's over here you
see the it's the second harmonic and
then the light blue third harmonic and
fourth and fifth and you could keep
going if you wanted to uh but the levels
dropped so much that you know we usually
don't bother
at least i don't bother above fifth
harmonic uh on this thing so
and the harmonics are important because
they tell us for example what could be
happening uh you know something like a
third harmonic means a symmetrical
problem which usually means sort of
driver excursion issue that limit that
you're hitting that you can't you know
but it hits it both above and below um
versus second harmonic and so there's
diagnostic information to be had from
just looking at what is the highest like
over here we can see
the second harmonic i think is
dominating here and perceptually that's
less audible than it would be
otherwise um
but look at some interesting events that
you can see when it's a high resolution
distortion measurement you see two
narrow peaks in here these almost always
indicate resonances meaning something
you know that frequency got activated
and it actually shows up both on
frequency response but sometimes a lot
more clearly in here in distortion plots
so it's not you know i guess it is
distortion but when it's narrow in
nature it indicates a resonance and uh
here we can see that there's the speaker
that uh you know the low frequencies are
okay and then we got something crazy
happening over here and then we go back
in it and we can see that the twitter is
pretty happy over here i think this was
the uh jbl a180 and it's a two and a
half wave where this the one of the
woofers allowed to play louder and is
breaking up and when it breaks up
distortion is climbing so right away a
high resolution
distortion graph allowed me to explain
something that would be very difficult
to try to guess as to what's happening
you don't have to become a speaker
designer now to understand
what is causing problems that this two
and a half way design solved one set of
problems but it created another problem
and this distortion is going up to two
and a half percent in the most sensitive
part of our hearing so likely this will
cause audibility issues and and lack of
clarity and and potentially brightness
you get uh out of this rising distortion
in this speaker
so a lot of insight but required a
higher resolution
measurement which uh thankfully a chirp
signal a log uh
sign will give you
now the
company that was complaining and saying
that distortion measurements are no good
is read one line for a manual saying oh
right here he says be careful you can
have ambient noise
well manual by the way a new version of
that manual doesn't say that i don't
know how old is manual manual
but a lot of people make a mistake of
what ambient noise is ambient noise is
heavily low frequency dominated
because as soon as you close the door in
the room you're filtering out a ton of
high frequencies they don't last through
the walls and everything if somebody's
talking next door and you're in another
room you put your ear against the wall
you're not hearing the high frequency
you just hear
the low frequencies because those have a
lot more energy and
they go through objects so
when i just showed you this issue over
here this is at one or two kilohertz and
uh
you're not going to have this kind of
ambient noise if you did and i'll show
you in a second you wouldn't be able to
see this high accuracy display so
whenever somebody tells you oh the room
noise is 40 db 50 db anyway it's like no
no that number means nothing 40 50 db at
what frequency if it's at 20 hertz i
couldn't care less you know i'm not
measuring speakers or at 20 hertz and i
can ignore the low frequency this
distortion anyway
at higher frequency the room could be
dead silent
the second thing by the way and i'm just
digressing beyond the slides you can put
the microphone close to the speaker
versus the ambient noise and as long as
you don't overload the microphone it's
not gonna pick up a very strong signal
and the distortions from speaker and the
noise ambient noise literally becomes in
the noise becomes unimportant and i'll
prove that
in a second
in case of measuring speakers versus
headphones the larger the room the
better the results are because what
happens that some of you hopefully are
familiar with as soon as you put a
speaker in the room the base gets this
sort of room modes where they
amplify and cancel and if you're
measuring distortion in a small room
those peaks and valleys go pretty high
up they may go up to 200 300 400 hertz
i'm fortunate enough to have an
extremely large space that i measured
the speakers in uh it's got about i
don't know 20 25 foot ceiling and
it's
massive in u.s terms it's the size of a
large three-car garage with a cathedral
cathedral or tall flat ceiling and very
very large volume and the volume
determines the
transition frequency the larger the
volume the lower that is that's why
large venues don't have room modes
because your volume gets so large the
room modes get pushed down to 20 30
hertz and don't matter
so uh if you have a small room and
you're measuring uh speakers in there
yes you do have to worry about the modal
response but frankly
that very low frequencies where modal
response is it's just not that important
first looking at distortion
the artifacts there still land at very
low frequencies where our hearing
threshold is quite high so we're just
not that interested and if i go back
oh
come on go back you know um yes the
distortion is shooting up over here but
i couldn't care less what's happening at
this region what i care about is what
all is happening here and where our
hearing threshold is very sensitive and
there is no modal response in here uh
certainly not in my room and i also
happen to live in middle of nowhere and
uh
the room i have is very very quiet uh
and i measure late at night to help with
that
okay
so can i prove to you everything i just
said absolutely so let's compare two
speakers and show how easy it is to you
know contrast performance of two
speakers with distortion measurements on
the left there's an expensive ten
thousand dollar speaker the revel f328
be
and uh
you know it's a tower speaker large
driver so it has no trouble producing 86
db and if the room noise was dominant i
should be able i would just get random
results but i'm not getting random
results uh look at for example over here
there's a resonance right here at 130
hertz 140 hertz and boom there's a sharp
peak there and i'm able to measure that
no problem and then look at how it's
able to measure down to very close to
you know 0.0 but not zero if i amplify
this graph you'll see that there's a
nice uh response over here so if i can
measure a speaker this clean and still
find problems it's a walk in the park to
measure speaker that i'll call
distortion factory is this gr research
lgk 2.0 and look at the distortions in
here you can't possibly dismiss this and
saying i saw useless all because of
noise
no it isn't because of noise it's a
little speaker and it's blowing his
brains out and it's getting distorted
not just at low frequencies that i said
i don't care about but now i've got a
distortion that's just gone way off the
scale even up to you know four or five
hundred hertz but even outside of that
look over here then there's a secondary
source of distortion also happening at
this higher frequency so
you know it's not just the base
frequencies that is distorting out and
compare this to a you know proper
speaker that doesn't have now again i
don't want you to compare these two
speakers they're in a completely
different category it's just the
speaking of the measurement system and
this is how you verify
if your measurements are accurate you do
a control test right uh here's a control
test take a very very clean speaker and
measure it and see if you see it by the
way you can go find the source of these
resonance and other measurements that
don't
uh rely on acoustic measurements and
you say yeah it's accurate and
therefore this for sure is telling me
there's problems this is where our
hearing is most sensitive in this region
and boy we have one and a half percent
distortion there that's a lot of
distortion that's being pumped in there
and despite just being 86 db and one
meter and that's 80 db at 2 meters and
by the way company spec is
shows measurements of this driver at 84
db already at one meter that's the
frequency response they show so this is
basically what the company's spec is and
the company's spec doesn't tell you what
the distortion is i'm showing you what
the distortion is and so it's critical
to measure this and say hey what's going
on what is the nature of the distortion
you can see the harmonic makeup of it
and decide whether it's excursion
limited or you know asynchronous uh uh
asymmetrical problems and all that could
be diagnosed from this
okay
so
please don't uh go by you know salesman
talk that ah you know this reviewers
measurements are too accurate and and
doesn't matter and we don't need
precision we do but we're very fortunate
lucky that professor farina from italy
uh invented this measurement technique
that's fast it's accurate and in the
right environment with the right
expertise and setting up the test
we can dig deep and find flaws from just
two simple things just like
frequency response measurement and
distortion so much can be diagnosed
about the speaker not just oh does it
play 20 kilos or 8 kilohertz and what
are the what does the simple crossover
do now we're able to do a ton in here of
course if this is
not information you understand or you
don't even use this kind of uh chirp
signal for measurement then yes you're
in the dark in ages and uh you know
you're not going to get this kind of
response if you step sign one frequency
at a time
you know you're never going to capture
these this kind of detail in here
okay i apologize for the technical
nature of this hopefully
sometime in the future you can come back
and watch this again and again again and
and dig deeper if you need to but for
now just that walking away point is
this is the modern way of my audio
precision i use with headphone systems
and then my clipboard
system i use for distortion measurement
and
room eq wizard if you use that that also
uses chirp signal it's the standard
today but sadly there's very little
discussion about what it does and what
it really do uh you know how it really
works okay
all right see you in a future video
bye-bye